[Musica]
diventare genitori e diventare papà è
un'esperienza meravigliosa
quando hai un figlio immediatamente
pensi al suo futuro a quello che potrei
fare per farlo crescere
pensi anche ai dettagli allo sport che
farà alla scuola che farà al lavoro che
riuscirà a fare quando diventerà grande
magari farà anche dei nipotini e ti farà
diventare nonno quando ti dicono tuo
figlio ha solo due anni e ti dicono che
tuo figlio autistico il futuro non lo
immagini più così il futuro diventa
nebuloso lo sport non lo immagini non lo
vedi la scuola sai che sarà un problema
il lavoro sai che non ci sarà come non
ci saranno i nipotini negli stati uniti
nasce un bambino autistico ogni 52
bambini in europa ci sono circa 6
milioni di persone con autismo un
piccolo stato
e in italia in italia ci sono 600 mila
persone con autismo
provo a ripeterlo 600.000 vuol dire un
bambino una persona ogni 100 persone
ogni 100 italiane e malgrado dei numeri
così importanti per i ragazzi con
autismo per le persone con autismo si fa
pochissimo pensate alle iniziative più
brillanti in italia e quando dico
brillanti intendo veramente luminosa e
non solo in italia in tutto il mondo
forse qualcuno riconosce la casa bianca
in questa immagine
il 2 aprile la giornata mondiale
sull'autismo i palazzi delle istituzioni
si illuminano di blu qualcuno ha deciso
che il blu è il colore dell'autismo i
palazzi si illuminano di blu bellissimo
utilissimo per sensibilizzare
assolutamente niente
per far fronte a tutte le esigenze delle
persone e dei ragazzi con autismo
il 3 aprile passato il blu di questi
bellissimi palazzi nelle scuole ancora
non ci sono gli insegnanti di sostegno
non ci sono il 5 di aprile non ci sono 6
di aprile non ci sono 7 di maggio e
neanche a giugno quando la scuola è
finita e quei pochi insegnanti di
sostegno che ci sono spessissimo non
sono preparate c'è bisogno di diagnosi
precoce mio figlio è stato diagnosticato
fortunata
da due anni la diagnosi precoce è
fondamentale ma poi ora che iniziano le
terapie fa 4 fa cinque anni fa sei anni
la diagnosi precoce diventa inutile in
qualche modo meglio che ci sia però deve
essere precoce davvero le terapie sono a
carico completamente delle famiglie il
sistema sanitario nazionale sull'autismo
passa poco e niente
e quel poco ce lo prendiamo tutti ce lo
prendiamo tutto io per esempio con la
mia famiglia per mio figlio noi abbiamo
fatto la psicomotricità la logopedia e
poi li poterà pia e tutto quello che si
può fare tutto quelle che famiglie
quello che le famiglie cercano di fare
per i loro figli
noi oltre a queste terapie classiche
abbiamo incominciato a fare la pizza
qualcuno ride la pizza mozzarella
pomodoro basilico il cibo più mangiato
dagli italiani e anche patrimonio
mondiale dell'umanità perché abbiamo
iniziato a fare la pizza perché quando
hai un bambino autistico come è successo
a me come è successo alla mia famiglia
tendi a chiuderti un po ti chiudi per
proteggere tuo figlio perché è difficile
quando il tuo bimbo incomincia a
sfarfallare in mezzo agli altri rimanere
sereno perché è difficile quando tuo
figlio incomincia a saltare senza un
motivo e vedi gli altri che lo guardano
rimanere sereno perché è difficile
quando tuo figlio parla al vento con
nessuno usa delle parole a vanvera e tu
vedi gli altri che ti guardano tuo
figlio urla e le persone ti giudicano
come un pessimo genitore per il tuo
figlio maleducato perché ringrazio
autisti ci sono dei bei ragazzoni non si
capisce
vedendoli che sono autistici noi perché
abbiamo iniziato a fare la pizza perché
con questa scusa abbiamo incominciato a
invitare tantissime persone a casa
nostra con la scusa della pizza gli
amici venivano a trovarci e io e mia
moglie potevamo finalmente stare coi
nostri amici con degli adulti ma
venivano anche gli altri bimbi venivano
i compagni di classe di mio figlio leo
venivano i figli dei nostri amici e li
ho poteva stare in un ambiente che
conosceva casa sua e fare tutto quello
che voleva poteva saltare poteva giocare
poteva tirar fuori la sua spada laser
leo usa la spada laser come oggetto per
fare amicizia con gli altri bambini
se ne porta sempre in giro 2 una lada
alla persona sconosciuta e una sera
tiene lui in questo modo giocano e lui
fa amicizia voleva tre persone si porta
l'amicizia da casa e oggi la data a me
questa mattina me l'ha data io gli ho
detto che andavo a parlare con delle
persone sconosciute le home ha detto
papa porta alla spada laser quindi sono
contento che leoni abbia aiutato anche
in questo incontro diventa difficile
dicevamo ma le home ha incominciato
giorno a fare la pizza con la sua mamma
a impastare la pizza sembrava una cosa
strana e parlandone anche con delle
persone esperte di autismo
ci hanno detto che effettivamente è
strano perché molti ragazzi non amano
toccare di impasti la farina l'acqua
tanto è vero che a un certo punto noi ci
siamo detti con mia moglie ma se leo che
è piccolino riesce per gioco a impastare
la parola pasta la pizza forse anche
ragazzi più grandi
lo possono fare ragazzi autistici più
grandi e così abbiamo invitato a casa
nostra
alessandro lorenzo gabriele lollo matteo
il gigante buono una serie di ragazzi in
età da lavoro grandi fra i 18 e 24 anni
e abbiamo parlato con i loro genitori
quello che per noi hanno un gioco fa
abbiamo detto questi genitori potrebbe
diventare invece un'opportunità di
futuro quel futuro che non vi diamo noi
a volte diciamo così dice spettro
autistico perché diventa un fantasma
il futuro per noi è un fantasma e invece
con la pizza abbiamo pensato di potergli
dare forma non solo quella tonda e
allora abbiamo incominciato organizzare
un corso per fare i pizzaioli
anche qui ci dicevano ma i ragazzi non
ce la faranno mai troppe variabili fare
la pizza
ci sono troppe variabili effettivamente
è andata come ci avevano detto abbiamo
iniziato con un gruppo di dieci ragazzi
e i primi che hanno messo le mani
dell'impasto hanno risposto nella
maniera che i libri ci dicevano corretta
hanno messo le mani l'impasto è breve
che schifo molti di loro ma non tu
molti di loro ma non tutti per esempio
alessandro ha incominciato a fare delle
pizze in maniera meravigliosa il suo
insegnante suo maestro noi chiamiamo
maestro mi ha insegnato che le pizze
vanno schiaffeggiate dall'interno verso
l'esterno
perché in questo modo l'ossigeno ma nel
cornicione e il carroccio di rimane più
morbido più buono e alessandro lo fa in
maniera meravigliosa lo stesso maestro
due settimane dopo ha spiegato accidenti
per il nome dico ha spiegato ad
alessandro che l'impasto della pizza una
cosa viva perché si fa con il lievito
madre perché cresce perché va fatto
riposare per 72 ore
bene alessandro ha smesso di fare le
pizze
adesso alcuni vogliono sorriso perché
hanno capito al volo e noi ci abbiamo
messo due settimane a capire le cose
vive non si schiaffeggiano alessandro
autistico interpretazione letterale le
cose vive non si schiaffeggiano
alessandro ha smesso di fare le pizze
gli abbiamo dovuto dire che deve
coccolarle e lui ha iniziato a coccolare
la pizza
noi siamo gli unici al mondo che fanno
la pizza coccolata altro che etica
rispetto anche per l'impasto alessandro
ha imparato a fare le pizze e con lui ha
imparato a farle matteo matteo il
gigante buono ragazzo autistico di due
metri è enorme e a una vocina bianca
quando parla è uno spasso è una
meraviglia a vedersi alessandro mattioli
imparato a fare le pizze errore
l'abbiamo iscritti al campionato
mondiale della pizza 700 pizzaioli
provenienti da tutto il mondo dal
giappone dalla groenlandia dalle america
dall'africa 700 pizzaioli potevamo
iscrivervi a una sezione speciale come
si fa spesso con le persone disabili
certo avremmo vinto di sicuro erano gli
unici due pizzaioli disabili 1 primo e
l'altro secondo abbiamo deciso
iscriverli con tutti gli altri 700 per
noi era un gioco non è una gara bene in
questo gioco i due pizzaioli autistici
sono arrivati entrambi nei primi cento
la pizza coccolata ha spaccato si
direbbe
ma qual è la cosa importante non è
arrivare nei primi cento e aver
dimostrato che si può fare aver
dimostrato che i ragazzi possono
imparare un mestiere anche uno di quelli
che sui libri ci viene raccontato che
non possono fare perché hanno un pessimo
rapporto con la farina l'acqua e queste
cose che hanno un'esperienza tattile
strada ma per fare un ristorante servono
anche i camerieri i pizzaioli non sono
sufficienti cosa abbiamo fatto
i ragazzi che non riuscivano a lavorare
l'impasto e abbiamo messi a fare i
camerieri abbiamo fatto per loro un
corso di mise en plus
io non sapevo neanche cosa fosse la mise
en plus non mi sono mai occupato di
ristorazione prima di pizza out che il
nome di questo ristorante comunque gli
abbiamo insegnato a servire in maniera
professionale a sparecchiare e
apparecchiare in maniera professionale
mentre lo facevamo ci siamo accorti di
mille difficoltà
parliamo di ragazzi autistici molti di
loro fanno fatica enorme fatica a
relazionarsi con gli altri
molti di loro fanno fatica a parlare con
gli altri
allora abbiamo chiesto a una
multinazionale di cui non faccio il nome
per non fare pubblicità se poteva
costruire per noi una app un'app visiva
fatta tutta in comunicazione aumentativa
tutta per immagini
in questo modo attraverso le immagini i
ragazzi prendono le comande in maniera
incredibilmente corretta vanno dalla
persona sorta di tavolo e con le loro
immagini riconoscono le pizze
riconoscono gli ingredienti e fanno i
camerieri
ma lo fanno come tutti gli altri
camerieri certo la tecnologia rivaluta
lo stesso è successo con le pizze
gli ho raccontato che i ragazzi sono
diventati straordinario a fare le pizze
ma quando prendono le pizze con la pala
e le mettono il forno le dimenticano nel
forno le bruciano tutte perché l'autismo
una brutta bestia si girano fanno le
altre quella la dimenticano ci siamo
inventati esiste già l'abbiamo solo
fatto modificare un formula tunnel c'è
una ruota che gira sempre i ragazzi
appoggiano loro pizza su questa ruota la
ruota porta l'impasto dentro il forno il
formula cuoce la stessa volta lo porta
fuori e l'altro a cambiare l'autistico
lo prendo
porta in sala aprire la mente aprire il
cuore a primi pensieri ci fa trovare
delle soluzioni creative che
costruiscono inclusione pensate il 9
luglio proprio per lavorare pienamente
sull'inclusione a 360 gradi sia mandati
al senato della repubblica a fare le
pizze e stata un'esperienza incredibile
ma vedete la conferenza stampa a un
certo punto francesco si alzato e nel
detenuti colori ai giornalisti
un'esperienza piacevolissima ma che cosa
è successo che i senatori della
repubblica hanno capito profondamente
che cos'è l'autismo che cos'è questo
spettro che ha dimensioni e persone
completamente diverse una dall'altra
hanno capito che si possono fare un
sacco di cose e con loro stiamo
lavorando a una legge che faciliti
l'accesso nel mondo del lavoro dei
ragazzi autistici una legge che speriamo
non sia solo italiana che diventi una
legge che si possa esportare in altri
luoghi in cui le aziende possano pensare
di assumere delle persone con autismo
non per responsabilità sociale
non perché sono buone ma perché i
ragazzi sono a tutti gli effetti capaci
di essere produttivi
quando i ragazzi lavorano diventano
straordinariamente capaci efficaci sale
l'autostima e fanno delle cose
incredibili
pensate che noi abbiamo fatto 100 serate
in giro per l'italia in cento ristoranti
diverse dal veneto alla calabria la
sicilia le marche ci manca solo la
sardegna
poi abbiamo girato tutta italia 100
serate abbiamo sfornato 30.000 pizze e
servite 30.000 pizze e qualcuno si
diceva che sarebbe stato impossibile
in realtà si possono fare davvero un
sacco di cose aprendosi aprendosi
ascoltando quello che i ragazzi sono in
grado di fare e costruendo le situazioni
per poterglielo far fare dopo la visita
al senato e il lavoro per costruire il
lavoro abbiamo pensato che i nostri
ragazzi potessero finalmente assumere un
ruolo diverso nella società non più di
genti pazienti
disabili handicappati ma lavoratori
guardate in questo momento
voi tutti in sala pagate la pensione di
invalidità ai miei ragazzi
dal momento che noi assumeremo i ragazzi
loro pagheranno la vostra di pensione e
questa la vera rivoluzione è questa
l'inclusione vera
[Applauso]
[Musica]